[Musique]
là j'ai pu rencontrer une très belle
personne que voilà avec laquelle
j'espère pouvoir rester en contact
encore longtemps parce que c'est
vraiment une personne qui commence à
avoir beaucoup d'importance pour moi
[Musique]
on a tous un point commun c'est qu'on
est passionné parce qu'on fait et
passionné donc toute par notre quartier
par notre histoire nos histoires et par
la rencontre le partage avec les gens je
reçois jamais quelqu'un si je suis pas
là si j'ai pas le temps de m'en occuper
utiliser à l'endroit
à l'envers
aussi ce qui est agréable pour moi c'est
que les gens qui font la démarche de
venir chercher sur la coopérative Hôtel
du Nord sont des gens qui cherchent un
peu autre chose qu'un hébergement tout
cru
et qui cherche autre chose que du
tourisme lambda
on est aussi dans les plateformes qui
incitent à l'annulation au dernier
moment à être dans une relation de avec
tous ces systèmes de notation aussi des
relations qui sont pas forcément saines
et de l'hospitalité et ça plusieurs
autres ont vu que voilà quand des gens
arrivaient par des plateformes on va
dire marchandes ils avaient tendance à
les traiter plutôt comme des servants
que quand ils arrivaient par Hôtel du
Nord donc on s'est dit on veut recréer
une plateforme il faut qu'elle soit
complètement différente de celle qui
existe donc pas de comparateur pas de
notes
[Musique]